a little reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and it's jump here hopefully you
guys had a good Memorial Day we're gonna
watch the honest trailers for a cat
Robin oh well I better I knew the head
of that a100 I'm so excited before we go
into this I want to be a shout out to a
special company screen junkies squat
junkies plus a couple months ago I
filmed an episode movie vs. movie John
flexors put dangerous show and it's a
really cool segment where basically you
keep pulling out movies and it's like
you're all debating about which movie
you should watch that night you know I
ever had that situation like what should
we watch next and I did that with rock
corn edge-on Flickinger and the episode
is now up we watch the whole thing I
thought it was really fun episode I
think I didn't know you filmed it and I
am NOT biased when I say it was very fun
to do I really had a good time but you
have to get a screen junkies Plus
account to watch it but yeah get it get
it accounts worth it I asked me to know
this plus it gives you access to movie
bites a couple days early alright John
and I haven't seen this but I like don't
remember I've never really jack [ __ ]
about this film I add it to my favorites
I haven't we haven't seen it since it
for the opening night it came out all
those years ago so let's get into this
oh yeah man what year was that woody was
Scott mance come on would you hide I
don't know
mm poor boy from Utah ha ha Pete off
comes a song reminder no matter what
happens within the Wonder Woman the bar
for female-led superhero movies it's
really oh really low fat around people
you see the best DC has to offer revisit
the worst if it's lawfully directed
insanely edited yeah when you're 14
you'll realize how horrible the solid
determine or lease just terribly quickly
ridiculously acted pile of cat bar that
came out just one year before bad going
to be good job but feels more like the
spiritual sequel the dilated Robin she's
like if you women a bad name
nice Selina Kyle just kidding this would
be a nothing to do with the same to do
and meet some random lady named patience
Phillips a graphic designer
with 200 films horniest co-workers we
have a wing man sandwich 12 o'clock
she's supposed to be a probably very
wrap with intelli Barry is the exact
opposite of that they'll just bury her
in plus size clothes and make her super
clumsy how friends we have rebound
change when a cat French kisses her dead
body on a pile of garbage
patients will become Catwoman a woman
with other new powers of a cat why is he
getting off the cat dead
and be it disgusting amount of tuna what
I said well I don't know seeing a doctor
about any of this
she'll just go to the graves cats period
women and give herself a haircut watch a
film that takes a step forward their
original superhero take eight steps back
by having her do battle against
moisturizer the evil of moisture
anesthetics execs Sharon Stone gets to
vent some of her personal frustrations
with Hollywood everything they wanted me
to be job and then I turned 40 I mean
for me away well releasing a product
that the class-action lawsuit waiting to
happen
stop easiness and your face cynically no
I'm pretty sure that probably get song
called that cattleman doing anything she
could literally sit her own movie out
and nothing would change
could we mine we're superheroes hit
their low poised full of iconically
crappy moments like the playground scene
the emo dance oh and the bad credit card
maybe became without it but not to be
outdone
Caggiula makes its contribution to
garbage culture and those here to scape
a basketball ever filled my pleasure you
stand there drilling for each other I've
done help basketball words remember any
shaking your ass at it kids or watch it
oh why so why cuz this ain't this is for
your blue for you and get back girls cuz
it's not for you either or you bad bad
bad or you person with eyes and ears
this is a really made for no one about
nothing that never should have existed I
feel badly positive contribution to the
world
what's Halle Berry's rabi speech thank
you for putting me in a piece of Scott
awful
she's a good talk about it now just
apologize for that towline and we're
good lightning maybe half of everything
else that Rory puss-in-boots
so Brett in the cash they suck into
Facebook ooh and good kid hello Steve ah
hey any Marvel was doing much better at
this point either thanks Rach remember
this name taser face you blow I'll do
the finger ring what happens to it I'm
not stuck by lightning same peg that
happens to everything else where the
hustles eat them chickens act
goodbye mr. Fogg Wow is a good reason I
stricken lot of that from my memory yeah
I don't remember like most of that I
kind of want to watch it again now just
to see how like unbelievably the only
thing I remember was what Sharon Stone
dies
I'm surprised I didn't include in the
trailer she gets knocked off a building
and she's like falling and you could
tell it's a dummy oh yeah 14 I was like
ah clearly fake that's really not a real
person
whatsoever full of 14-year old I
remember it not being good I don't know
it was 14 when I saw it so I did I
didn't register it like so terrible and
just what it is yeah this video also has
the benefit of everything being super
dated yeah you know because we don't do
these movies like that anymore
that's the funny thing about it is the
part I took away most was oh yeah there
was a time when comic book movies were
not so solid they were starting to like
dish them out more often but there was
very hit and miss I know spider-man 3 is
that one that one of the things that you
like that a lot of people don't and I
don't look that's a messy movie
I just like parts of it yeah yeah the
doochie spider-man scheme Oh Peter I
love you but even the daredevil sequence
without fighting in the playground ahead
the Fantastic Four and then seeing this
I was like wow holy crap I totally
forgot there was like some really awful
comp removi though it was kept coming
out around the same time yeah one of
mostly question of look yeah it's crazy
it's crazy how much they've evolved so
much especially after seeing this DC was
I mean they have Wonder Woman coming out
which is getting great feedback right
now and we're gonna do a video on its
early reaction you know they were the
first ones to do a solo female superhero
with Catwoman now I'm very rigorous she
did she's not a hero
it wasn't even connected of Batman it
was pretty bad yeah I guess that awful
yeah I guess that's the one thing that
the bit like having the barrier so thin
between fans and studios no ass feel
like the one that official thing about
that is we get a lot less of these
movies where they're like hey let's
taking name it change everything you
know what I mean the bad franchise was
like doomed for a while with I mean
Batman Forever so as some people really
like it I think it's Batman Robin
Terrell in a Catwoman and then a little
bit of or been in beginnings they got
this which was like yes I remember the
announcement Jenna oh my god that was
very odd immediately I was like oh no
it's not that's fully made up has
nothing to do with Selina Kyle yet
Constance Phillips is that there's some
pretty horrible things that I remember
Benjamin Bragg's is he's the cop who's
dating the Catwoman and he doesn't know
she's Catwoman even though she
eventually changes her hair hmm
and only one woman in the city has hair
like her good one it's not like that
mask of doing art yeah yeah the guys
save african-american female with a
specific narrative fun and you know
Halle Berry it's like those the eye
holes or one has a lot of having her
face a builder or height like those do
as you like your costume that's the
other thing too is nowadays like we
redesigned costumes to make them at
least practical and that was like the
least
a superhero costume ever seen what I
also remember was a scene where she's on
to her he's pretty sure it's her but
then he sees the writing of like I think
it's her name like page it's like she
writes it when she's just herself and
then when her and when she turned into
Catwoman she writes it as that and then
the I don't know the forensic guy or
something who it was like the writing
looks at him a little Hendren the
handwriting looks similar it's like what
they see there's a slight difference
here so it's definitely him different if
you can yeah all right I'm gonna be
nobody would have ever thought to change
their and writing for different happen
uh mom it's like that even that big of a
difference
oh you see this this is a sign of it I
remember something stupid like this is
this I'm too insecure woman this is a
sign of a confident woman two very
different people to put yeah it's Brad
ah
Benjamin Bratt in the MCU now oh yeah
any more you got killed off that
post-credits II know which one dr.
strange that's that's right you just
ruined off your syringe for you guys I
most important character and all of dr.
strange I'm sure you guys were pissed
about that I'm gonna be honest I don't
remember that post-credit scene at all -
it's a legend for you right come on you
chose men's remember oh is that what
happens ari I forgot I remember it had
hang on I have two extra spoiler
well guys yeah I got go subscribe to
screen junkies man is a great honest
trailer I love it when they do the the
bad movies I think it's great when they
do like the ones that are known to be
bad they're always the fun one yeah and
especially a movie like this work we
have so much context to draw from and
like the the scenery has changed so much
like going back to a film like this is
kind of a treat because it shows you
just how far we've come and how that
could have been way longer this whole
honest trailer they could have had I'd
have watched twenty men dig they could
have had a lot more scenes in there yeah
all right guys well you can subscribe to
screen jump goodies go check out screen
junkies plus for my episode John
clicksters on there no reactions is just
a lot of movie talk on there like a
25-minute episode and also the whole
segment and all the other exclusive
screen junkies plus episodes or
fantastic I have a Yap and I know I paid
monthly for it free concern I don't
think I came up with a yearly for it oh
you get that big one because I not be
worried until Christmas time yeah when
I'm out of money and I get this Charlie
come back crap man I should've canceled
it you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification will be notified
every one of our videos is out dat John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram go
check out our patreon help support the
channel of becoming a member of the
patreon community got a lot of exclusive
perks and rewards on there for you guys
come cuddle with us much love to all my
brothers and sisters